comment les choses arrivent dans la vie
comment il faut le voir pour le croire
ce jour là dont je vous parle il devait
être exactement 11h30 11h45 à peu près
et il y avait un monde fou au café chez
pépettes au bar palace à bab el oued en
plein la vue de la boue arrière comme
c'est la vérité c'est pas c'est pas le
café chez vous avez dû connaître et
chacun c'était l'heure de l'apéritif
chacun paie sa tournée la tienne la
mienne la tienne la mienne la tienne la
mienne j'en avais que c'était un peu la
sienne la sienne la sienne parce que
vous avez des au sein dans la poche et à
cette heure ci qui on voit rentrer à
cette heure ci qui envoie rentré au café
car oui tant lui même carlito en
personne il se pointe devant le comptoir
et comme si vous venez d'être nommé
ministre la culture et des beaux-arts
ils demandent aux parents avaient pâti
lui dit je voudrais un café bien chaud
bien servi bien sucré sp pas le cas le
patron bon boulot il était amusé lui
cire son café ils se disent ils avaient
l'habitude des barjots des moitié fou
dès 2000 ou des fous entier il avait
c'était parce qu'il banque helaba
il a dix pour cent cinquante fois je
vais perdre mon temps avec ce ça monte
là c'est pas la peine bon j'ai lu sur
son café puis ça fait rien vendu cher
son café ça fait rien le lendemain à 8
au jeu se repointe à la même heure comme
et avec plus de culot que la veille il
demande au patron je voudrais un café
bien chaud bien servi bien sucré et je
paye pas le patron bon goût groupe est
il sur son café il avait d'autres choses
à faire c'était lors du coup de feu avec
les kenyans et tout bon ça va
le surlendemain même même chanson mais
mr mêmes paroles ça commençait à devenir
un tube d'ailleurs c'était le matraquage
exactement et semer et je mets quoi un
ténor à la scala de milan il dit après
fait je voudrais un café bien chaud bien
servi bien sucré et je paye pas et le
manège comme ça ils durent pendant dix
jours dix jours dix jours du jour le
onzième jour mais pâtit dans l'avé maris
l'appel un copain lui qui ne l'ont pas
une armoire à glace pour dire que vous
dire que ceux qui ne l'ont pas la grâce
à dieu c'était vraiment quand on voulait
avoir de londres et qui avait du soleil
on se met à côté du lit c'était un
parasol à lui tout entier c'est un
parasol et lui dit écoute écoute chinaud
fais moi plaisir celui là qui vient tous
les jours
il commence non seulement il m'a pourri
la vie mais ils commencent hamas fixiez
et il m'a pompé l'air alors j'en peux
plus je suis comme ça je vais tomber
s'il vient demain tu vas te le prendre
tu vas t'occuper de lui et tu vas te
jeter comme une bouteille non consignés
en douceur
tu vas me jeter parce que j'en peux plus
de lui je ne peux plus j'en peux plus de
me tue le fait tranquillement le 11e
jour tu as we know it software comme
s'ils avaient une carte orange
d'abonnement paraît il ce point et ce
point est dit
je voudrais un café bien chaud bien
sucré bienservi espagne pas si l'on
s'approche de lui les yeux côtoient
vient vers toi toi viens viens dit moi
ça fait dix jours que tu viens comme ça
tu demandes un café bien chaud bien
sucré comme si c'était toi le directeur
de plantation de café dis moi tu n'as
pas peur swatch a pas peur campbellton
et le regard du budget moi j'ai pas peur
moins étroits qui a peur toi sinon il se
met à claquer de rire il n'en pouvait
plus de ribiers moi j'ai pas peur ah bon
il n'y a pas peur toi et quand et où se
trouve vers le comptoir est il alors
pour nous deux deux cafés rien sont bien
sucré bien servi et rentrait pas
à